don't recognize when you go out and you
dress and you speak who do you represent
when you go out as a woman in the
relationship your husband right so when
you're at school and you're in uniform
you represent the school yeah when you
go out as a child you represent your
parents if you have a man you represent
your man you're a couple so people are
going to know that if he sees you on a
on a podcast and you're doing God knows
what you're going to represent him
people are going to know that's
so-and-so's woman so you have to listen
to him you don't don't he doesn't tell
me what to do but I have to take his
feelings into account
do you flip that do you flip that and
does he represent you as well when he's
doing stuff yeah well then the U.S do
you have authority over him to give him
permission to do stuff or not yes
certainly he won't do anything that's
everything it works both ways but you
said you have but he has the final
decision it's not equal
okay okay yeah he has the final decision
if he's going to do something and he
says oh I'm gonna do that and I'm like
you know I don't agree with that because
it's been so long 32 years and counting
because it's been so long he I he will
know that there must be a reason behind
it that I don't agree with him now he
will either listen to me as I would do
him because I don't have to take
everything he says as gospel it's up to
me whether to take it or not and nine
times out of ten years I will listen to
him rather than listen to my friends
listen to their friends what about most
of us that haven't had 32 years and so
are you saying that I've been with my
man two years and I must what he says
goes this is what my struggle is what
I'm trying to say is you've been able to
build that trust you you've been able to
know that he's got your best interests
at heart yeah you've been able to know
that he has your rights your right
intentions but most of us haven't had 32
years to practice all that you know it
sounds like I can't adopt your position
can I say something do you know
something right you as a woman would
know within the first six months whoever
that man is for you I can't say that I
would know me personally I would not I
was a single parent just like you I was
a single parent and we split out but
when I met him back he was a single
parent
so I know that anything he says if it
jars in my heart I have to think they
must have you know what that don't feel
right let me discuss it but if I think
to myself I am not going to be a
detriment
then I'll go with it because it's not
harming me
so every if I think in my head as a
woman that what he's saying doesn't
benefit me or harms me I will discuss it
and then because it's not the fact that
oh what he says goes I will discuss it
with him and I want to hear where he's
coming from because all right then for
instance you've got a man and you both
of you have a favorite artists
and the favorite artist gives you two
free tickets to go
and then your man looks at tick and says
you know what you're not going what
would you do
like this conversation is going to
happen with my man anyway now honestly I
think that I think the modern
relationship is way too uh it wasn't no
let me say the modern relationship I'm
looking for is way too equal in terms of
opinion and position there's there's a
conversation it's about what's making me
happy and if it's taking my best friend
to that concert he wants to see me smile
and he wants to see me happy that's
what's going to happen in that concert
but you didn't answer the question so
the question was I asked you what would
you do like when he asks you to do
something that you don't want to do
but if it's in my best interest I cannot
put myself the only man or the only
being is God that can tell me by speech
by Grace
God says obey your man the man
he's my man he didn't put a ring on it
you should be with him until you put the
ring on it right but what I'm trying to
say is if I'm a feminist what does it
mean for me as a single woman that's
what I'm trying to understand from this
conversation okay so can I try to add a
little bit of context on it because it's
like a okay so basically what what
they're saying is okay so yes working
taking out the rubbish doing all of
these things are seen as as masculinity
right however I don't think we're
speaking in that regard because
obviously these are things that have to
be done you have to take out the rubbish
you have to work you have to do these
things but I think we're especially as a
single person however we're basically
saying but you're still a feminine that
doesn't make you masculine what makes
you masculine is when when you're like
so let's put everything in context now
so I said I made the same statement as
Auntie right
so I'm going to put things into context
if I wanted to go shopping in Tesco's
for example I don't need his permission
right because I'm going Tesco's and I'm
doing food shopping if somebody invites
me to a club
or some kind of event
then I need to sit down and speak to him
and explain to him where I'm going what
type of event is what kind of people are
there all right let's let's say for
example I'll put an outfit on and I put
on a short dress and and my breasts are
revealing okay now if he says to me you
look nice babe
go out and have a good time
as soon as he's finished that sentence
me and him are done because me I can't
be the guy like that to me that's a simp
okay so if my my man or my husband says
to me
you need to go back and you need to
change because what you're wearing
is inappropriate now look a lot of
people will be like no why why I compare
what I want if I want to work but you're
not you're not thinking because if you
if you're going out with your husband
right and you go to a club or a place
and you're wearing a short skirt and
your breasts are out you'll there's a
huge possibility that you're going to
put your husband in a situation no but
he's next to me
let me laugh let me land okay so for
example my fiance right if me and him
went out to a place and he wouldn't let
me wear that anyway in the first place
but let's say he did and we went out to
a place right and a guy comes and and
Taps my bum
it's less likely right and if he does do
that if I had a bbo you will attack my
ass not necessarily but look look look
we we have to go about intentions if I
come to a place and I'm properly covered
up jeans and a guy does that he's
getting smoked right there's no if so
but about it because this girl is
respecting herself she's dressed up
nicely and you've come out of your way
yeah and you've you've slapped her ass
now my fiance if he was with me right
and somebody did that
there's a huge possibility he's going to
jail for life but then you're wearing
tight jeans why not wear this on long
skirt in it if we're going if you're
going to do more you're going to do what
you can wear it alone
no nothing you can that's what you
should do then because no no you're
calling for it also with the little
tightness okay we're getting away from
the clothes hold on getting away from
close you guys this is what I'm so
confused about it Auntie you kind of did
it and then walked to a more agreeable
area do you guys talk about things that
are basic relationship Norms but you
like frame them in the most toxic way
possible I don't understand so you talk
about like if I'm gonna wear something
and go out to a club my boy my my
boyfriend my husband whatever is going
to approve of it which it to some extent
like can make sense in a relationship
context but if you flip that around if
your boyfriend or husband says I'm gonna
go out to party you know and there's
like you know 10 girls there and like
two guys I imagine you have to okay that
right you'd have to tell him whether or
not you give him permission to do that
no yes okay so you guys frame these
things like my my husband is the
ultimate Authority and blah blah but
that's not true for all you guys it's a
back and forth like you're gonna be
okaying what he does he's gonna be okay
what you do that has nothing to do with
masculinity or femininity or anything
like that that's just like two adults
having a relationship figuring out what
the boundaries are thank you yeah so so
what do you mean by your place when you
say auntie because what does he saying
this it is an equal exchange of
um looking up for each other no I think
with me I'm different because if I'm
gonna wear a short skirt and something
sexy I'm always going to work with my
with my man mostly I wear it at home
but if I want to go out and I'll say Tim
what do you think about this and do you
know what
what um Destiny said
what we've been saying it's just normal
no more respect for each other
and I respect him and his decisions and
his opinions and he will respect mine so
it's not like I'm blindly following
where he wants to go because Effie
wanted to go somewhere or talk to
certain people other sitting in the past
you know what I don't like your friends
and as a man I would say you know I'm
not going to say don't go out of him I'm
saying this watch out for this this is
what I spotted this this this and this
and I'll let him go ahead and eventually
he will not you know what you were right
so it's just about respect but I find
that these modern people now they don't
have the basic respect for each other
and as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible